una delegación del Estado colombiano y
otra de la guerrilla del eln reunidas en
Venezuela anunciaron que tras la primera
semana de noviembre reanudarán los
diálogos de paz las conversaciones
estarán auspiciadas por Venezuela Cuba y
Noruega
segundo día de motín en la cárcel de
latacunga en Ecuador vecinos y
familiares han sido evacuados de las
inmediaciones del centro penitenciario
en el que ayer las autoridades
confirmaron 15 muertos por los
enfrentamientos Tenemos reporte desde
Ecuador
Este martes el senado ruso aprobó por
unanimidad las leyes que ratifican los
tratados de anexión a Rusia de las
regiones de doniescance gerson y
saporiya solo falta la firma del
presidente Vladimir Putin para finalizar
el proceso de integración unilateral
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en nuestra región
porque una delegación del Estado
colombiano y otra de la guerrilla del
eln reunidas en Venezuela anunciaron que
retomarán los diálogos de paz después de
la primera semana de noviembre ambas
partes acordaron volver a las mesas de
diálogo en un proceso auspiciado por
Venezuela Cuba y Noruega recordemos que
las conversaciones de paz entre el
gobierno de Bogotá y la guerrilla fueron
congeladas bajo la presidencia de Iván
Duque y ahora reiniciar este proceso es
el primer paso hacia la paz total a la
que aspira el presidente Gustavo Petro
previamente Néstor rosanía director
ejecutivo del centro de estudios en
seguridad y paz de Colombia nos analizó
las perspectivas de este proceso de paz
Bueno lo primero importante es que ya
hay una metodología que se avanzó en el
gobierno de Santos ya hay unos puntos
que se limitaron en el gobierno de
Santos y ya hay un camino que se ha
avanzado no vamos a arrancar de Cero y
eso va a ahorrar mucho tiempo en la
negociación lo segundo en el lln sabe
que es estratégico llegar a un acuerdo
En este gobierno Un gobierno de
izquierda que puede ser más fácil llegar
a lo que tenía en gobiernos anteriores o
más de 20 años que estuvo el uribismo en
el poder y lo tercero es que también ya
hay un espacio político que abrieron las
FARC que se que saben que pueden llegar
a ser política y que ya tienen como unas
lecciones aprendidas de lo que fue el
proceso de paz con las Farc entonces
tienen varios elementos varias certezas
y claridades que antes no existían
continuamos en nuestra región en Ecuador
se registró el segundo día de motín en
la cárcel de la ciudad de latacunga en
el centro del país los vecinos y
familiares han sido desalojados de las
inmediaciones del centro penal en el que
ayer murieron al menos 15 personas en
medio de los enfrentamientos el número
de presos fallecidos en las cárceles de
Ecuador en este 2022 se acerca ya al
centenar nuestro corresponsal en Quito
Gustavo Ortega con los detalles
por segundo día la cárcel de latacunga
en la provincia de cotopaxi escenario de
amotinamientos carcelarios El
lanzamiento se inició el día lunes y
hasta la fecha la fiscalía general del
estado informo que ha levantado 15
cadáveres y contabilizado 20 personas
heridas en un país donde la violencia
Cáceres una noticia que se repite
frecuentemente en el país andino el
gobierno ecuatoriano había informado que
las seis de la tarde del día lunes
contaba con el control del centro
carcelario de latacunga pero nuevas
detonaciones se escucharon en el centro
penitenciario que ocasionó el desarrollo
de familiares la prensa que abordaba lo
sucedido ya hace 24 horas y motivaba si
el ingreso de personal militar y un
tanque del ejército a la cárcel ubicada
en la sierra centro de Ecuador las
autoridades no han emitido un informe
oficial por el nuevo amotinamiento 8
masacres se registran en Ecuador desde
el año 2021 en su mayoría por el control
de territorio que ha generado una guerra
sin precedentes por los recursos en
distintas cárceles del país que se
produjeron el mes de febrero Julio
septiembre noviembre del año 2021
mientras que los que va de año 2022 se
han producido en el mes de abril mayo
julio y octubre contabilizando 366
personas asesinadas dentro de las
cárceles vamos ahora con información
económica la bolsa de Nueva York
suspendió la cotización de la acción de
Twitter ya que los títulos se
valorizaban en más del 12%. después de
que el portal especializado bloomberg
news asegurará que el multimillonario y
lo más iba a seguir adelante con la
compra de la compañía por 44 mil
millones de dólares Twitter confirmó la
oferta e informó estar dispuesto a
concluir la transacción recordemos que
el dueño de tesla está en una disputa
legal con la red social después de
declarar que ya no le interesaba el
negocio la suerte ahora del
multimillonario acuerdo será sometida a
juicio que durará cinco días a partir
del 17 de octubre en un tribunal
empresarial de Delaware
vamos ahora con información de la guerra
en Ucrania Este martes el senado ruso
aprobó por unanimidad la anexión de
doniesk lugans gerson y saporiya a la
federación rusa a la espera de la firma
del presidente ruso Vladimir Putin que
supondrá el punto y final a este proceso
unilateral el conflicto sigue escalando
sobre el terreno por otro lado el
kremlin informó que 200.000 hombres se
han alistado ya al ejército en el marco
de la movilización parcial obligatoria y
kiev reivindica nuevos avances en el sur
y el este del país
la decisión se ha tomado por unanimidad
tal como ocurrió en la víspera en la
duma Este martes los miembros del senado
ratificaron la incorporación de las
autoproclamadas republicas de doniach y
logans y las provincias de gersoni
zaporitja como parte de la federación
rusa los territorios anexados
unilateralmente por el kremlin suponen
cerca del 18% del territorio reconocido
internacionalmente a Ucrania
paralelo Moscú sigue entrenando a miles
de soldados para llevarlos al frente de
batalla tras su llamado a la
movilización parcial de hace dos semanas
al día de hoy más de 200.000 personas se
han incorporado a las fuerzas armadas he
ordenado que se les proporcione a todos
ellos uniformes y otros equipos
necesarios y se les nombre en puestos
militares el personal de servicio debe
ser enviada a las zonas de combate
después del fin del entrenamiento y el
ensayo
en el terreno la arremetida continúa
desde Ucrania temen que los ataques del
ejército ruso contra infraestructuras
estratégicas puedan redoblarse con la
llegada del Invierno no obstante en kiev
siguen reivindicando sus avances en el
sur y el oeste liberando según las
autoridades varias localidades a las
orillas del río nipro Los logros
militares los reflejan estos soldados
ucranianos izando banderas en pueblos de
jarqui y gerson
hay nuevos asentamientos liberados en
varias regiones continúan los combates
feroces en muchas áreas del frente pero
la perspectiva de estas hostilidades
siendo obvia cada vez más ocupantes
están tratando de escapar el ejército
enemigo está sufriendo más y más bajas y
hay una comprensión creciente de que
Rusia cometió un error al ir a la guerra
contra Ucrania pese a los llamados de
nuevas sanciones internacionales
Moscú sigue escalando su ofensiva dentro
y fuera de Ucrania
cambiamos de información igual que hizo
ayer el líder supremo de Irán el ayatolá
alija menei hoy el presidente iraní
Ibrahim Racing acusó a Estados Unidos y
a Israel de organizar las protestas por
la muerte de
maxamos que la joven murió tras ser
detenida por la policía de la moral y
que fue el mismo día de su funeral el 17
de septiembre cuando se desató el
movimiento contra la represión y la
brutalidad del régimen de Teherán raíz y
pidió unidad nacional mientras las
protestas se extienden por los centros
educativos del país escuchemos las
palabras del presidente iraní
porque los enemigos porque Estados
Unidos y el régimensionista conspiraron
contra nuestra nación nuestro país y
nuestra Revolución y crearon estos
disturbios como dijo el líder supremo
nuestro país Está avanzando y los
enemigos no quieren que nuestro país
progresen
y en otras noticias Corea pasaporte
disparó un misil balístico sobre Japón
por primera vez en cinco años como
respuesta Tokio activó su sistema de
alerta antimisiles y emitió una inusual
advertencia para que la población
buscará Refugio los detalles en el
siguiente informe aquí va era una mañana
normal en Japón hasta que ocurrió esto
tenemos noticias de última hora el
gobierno japonés advierte que Corea del
Norte parece haber lanzado al menos un
misil balístico existe la posibilidad de
que se dirija a Japón el gobierno está
llamando a todos en el país a permanecer
en el interior o encontrar un refugio
inmediatamente
en todo Japón en pequeños pueblos y
grandes ciudades sonaron las sirenas
junto con un mensaje ominoso
un misil ha sido lanzado Corea del Norte
parece haber lanzado un misil
mensajes de advertencia llegaron a los
teléfonos los trenes de alta velocidad
se detuvieron abruptamente con el mismo
mensaje repetido en bucle
[Música]
se dio el visto bueno unos 20 minutos
después el misil cayó en el Pacífico
pero el daño estaba hecho el país estaba
sacudido y enfadado
vivo en un apartamento Así que no tengo
sótano cuando me dijeron que me pusiera
cubierto bajo tierra mi reacción sincera
fue realmente no sé qué hacer aunque no
haya sanciones quiero que el gobierno
adopte una postura más firme frente a
Corea del Norte
me sentía asustada si su tecnología ha
mejorado significa que están trabajando
en ello a diario Me preocupa que algún
día puedan fabricar un misil potente
fue la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano sobrevoló Japón desde 2017
las autoridades calificaron en el
disparo como un acto imprudente y
dijeron que la distancia de vuelo
estimada de este misil en particular Era
la más larga entre los cohetes lanzados
anteriormente
a finales de 2024 todos los dispositivos
móviles y tabletas comercializados en la
Unión Europea deberán poder recargarse
con un cargador universal es la Norma
que aprobó el parlamento europeo Este
martes tras una década de negociaciones
entre las compañías tecnológicas Apple
se perfila como la más afectada por su
amplio abanico de puertos de carga
nuestra corresponsal en Bruselas Esther
Herrera con los detalles han llegado a
plantear la cantidad de cables que
llegamos a acumular a lo largo de
nuestra vida Pues bien en la Unión
Europea esto pronto va a poder tener un
fin está maraña de cabras de cables
porque la el parlamento europeo ha dado
luz verde definitiva que a partir de
2024 Máximo en un máximo de dos años
puede haber solo un solo dispositivo un
solo cargador este el usbc que pueda
ayudar a cargar todos los dispositivos
electrónicos se trata de tabletas
también de teléfonos de cámaras de vídeo
de teléfono también videoco e incluso
también auriculares o también libros
electrónicos podrán utilizar este único
dispositivo todos los fabricantes todas
las marcas sin excepción tendrán que
adecuarse a esta nueva Norma si quieren
vender sus productos dentro de la Unión
Europea qué pasa con los ordenadores
portátiles también les va a afectar pero
van a tener un poco más de tiempo en
lugar de 2024 van a tener hasta un
máximo de 4 años para poder adaptarse a
la nueva normativa para la Unión Europea
en cualquier caso se trata de un gran
éxito que otros países y otras regiones
del mundo también deberían copiar porque
tiene un verdadero una verdadera
consecuencia también para los
consumidores para el bolsillo entonces
Se podrían ahorrar 250 millones de euros
y también un impacto para el medio
ambiente se reduce este impacto porque
en la Unión Europea aproximadamente
14.000 toneladas de cables y de
cargadores acaban en la basura en toda
la Unión Europea Así que para la Unión
Europea se trata de un gran éxito que
tiene también un positivo en el medio
ambiente y también para los consumidores
cerramos conciencia tres científicos
comparten el premio Nobel de física de
este año 2022 por sus aportes a la
mecánica cuántica se trata de
clauser y anton sus hallazgos con
fotones entrelazados abren un nuevo
campo para las tecnologías de la
comunicación más en el siguiente informe
poco antes de cumplirse el mediodía en
estocolmo la Real Academia sueca de
ciencias anunció que serían tres los
ganadores del premio Nobel de física de
este año Alan aspecto de Francia John
closer de Estados Unidos y anton
sailinger de Austria recibieron el
premio por experimentos con fotones
entrelazados que establecieron la
violación de las desigualdades de Bell y
fueron Pioneros en la ciencia de la
información cuántica
quien trabaja en la universidad de Viena
habló tras el anuncio admitió estar
sorprendido e insistió en que el premio
fue un esfuerzo de colaboración
eso solo fue posible porque tuve la
oportunidad desde muy temprano de hacer
las cosas que me interesaban en física
sin pensar si podría tener un propósito
en alguna parte
por el contrario Durante los primeros
días de los experimentos la prensa me
preguntaba para qué servía y yo decía
puedo decirle con orgullo que es inútil
Solo estoy haciendo esto por curiosidad
porque estaba completamente fascinado
por la física cuántica desde la primera
vez que escuché de ella
se espera que el trabajo del Trío
conduzca importantes avances en la
computación cuántica y la tecnología de
detección el entrelazamiento cuántico
permite conectar dos partículas sin
enviar ninguna señal entre ellas durante
la tarde del 4 de octubre la asamblea
nacional de Francia ovacionó aspe el
décimo cuarto ganador francés del premio
otro impulso al sector de la ciencia y
la tecnología del país
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com enseguida volvemos
[Música]